The picture is not for me
It became a photograph for those people
me
Hmm
My dad sent me a message when I picked up lenses and cameras to see Mr. Toh
I felt like I was sending
I began to feel that I had to record as a photographer
At first my heart was sunk, but I will take pictures and talk with the people in the city
By repeating things I recover my mind little by little
I was able to
What they're pouring in It's brought up looking at their fathers' backs and has the industry in this town
I want to go
Everyone is now headed for a tremendous future compared to five years ago
I feel that I am having a good time and having fun and exciting and exciting
I also like to talk about that together
me